I think one thing I'm most excited about  with Twitter is he lost 750 million  dollars of a advertising per year  because 50 of the top 100 advertisers  dropped off that's a big number  and to replace that 750 million dollars  all he needs  is 7.7 million people out of his you  know 250 million active followers to pay  eight bucks a month if 7.7 million  people on Twitter pay 8 bucks a month he  no longer needs those 750 million  dollars of advertisers I'm willing to  say if 30 million people pay eight bucks  a month on Twitter it's game over he  doesn't have to bow down to Big Pharma  he doesn't have to bow down to nobody he  becomes the biggest threat in  everybody's business big Pharma one of  these big advertisers are worried the  fact that they may not need their money